I got to signing up I'm not really shot
Anderson cuz I start my [ __ ] yeah young
and impatient I don't have travel
shakers an ecosystem see I had too much
complaining don't do this simple fun I
take the stairs just oozes all I keep
hearing just step your [ __ ] in and get
it done [ __ ] going through motions I'm
telling miss Lee a focus on making
history warp is for my intensity core
you cannot limit me moments like these
are hard to find
I just want what's mine the crown enter
title don't let me make you do over rep
and do that like a hundred words four
minutes till no one hear you hard to
hear you over the left that my
conference headed I'm ready I wanted it
better don't none of you scare me what
happened to a sestra maintaining fact
that you made it or that everybody took
you overcompensating you read for your
friends I rest little girl I'm up stakes
and dreams you out chasing girls a wall
you're getting your degree you're
aspiring or sitting on your couch and
dreaming it just comes down to doing and
for sports personalities there's no
greater place than Twitter because
there's so much conversation and if
you're a well-rounded sports person and
has thoughts on everything from the NHL
to MMA you can actually have unlimited
opportunities to produce two-minute
videos all day every day forever on
subject matters that are trending and
being talked about all of which are
giving you greater opportunity to be
discovered because people are hitting
those hashtags watching those
conversations you can reply to people
that are more famous than you you can
reply and make content in response to
another famous writer or athlete talking
about it it's just gaming the system
you're you know you can go and walk into
any conversation in any park in the
world right now if there's 20 people
talking about something and none of them
know what you sports an amazing 20 eyes
standing around in a park debating
LeBron versus Jordan and you could
literally walk up to that park and you
just start talking and you're part of
them
and you may make the point that one or
change the conversation or you said the
ridiculous thing they got everybody to
kick you out but that's what Twitter is
Twitter is incredible for that
especially for sports commentators and
I'm just so sad because I get an email
every day from a kid from Michigan and
Syracuse like Gary I want to be in the
sports but I don't what can you let me
get an internship at the Daily News are
you stupid
like that's a needle in a haystack and
that's still how people are thinking
about it even 22 year olds who are
natively being living in this
environment there's such an opportunity
on Twitter for sports so crazy like yeah
and not only that like the writers are
the athletes are the coaches are than
you said and everybody right is there
anything trending on Twitter right now
about sports thank you thank you
michael phelps great michael phelps is
trending right now let's see why michael
phelps racing a shark reminds me michael
phelps is apparently tired of racing
humans he decided to take on a shark as
real my replying right now to the USA
Today and be like Michael Phelps is a
genius well Mike what people don't
understand [ __ ] up that do it anyway
my damn self I'm just going to do it
something I don't normally do
hey guys just testing something I'm
writing my new book crushing it and I'm
giving an example of something I think
is smart to do on Twitter so I'm jumping
into this Michael Phelps is racing a
shark article first but I'd normally
probably triple check and make sure it's
real news that's true but USA Today I
respect and trust you so here's where
I'm going I think Michael Phelps is a
genius I think he's hacked in culture I
think that there's a white space for
somebody to play the even Evel Knievel
of 20 20 20 20 20 18 I think Michael is
clearly still passionate about swimming
and things of that nature so that's an
interesting insight that he's going down
this path if he is because again I
didn't triple check but I'm just doing
this on a whim testing something but my
punch line in this is this is brilliant
this will capture some attention I have
no idea of - sharks are you can beat
them but if he beats a shark I think
that leads to the next race interesting
and so I will pay you 20 bucks for a
pay-per-view of watching Michael Phelps
swim against us something would you pay
20 bucks to watch Michael Phelps place
against a shark I hope you guys heard
that that's it and basically basically
what I just did right now so here's
where it gets interesting right so I
replied in video form - this right right
and so everybody replied sway let's see
if it shows up it's not uploaded yet but
I'll show you in a minute so that's it
that's like what I think dunk should do
it don't decided to take his huge
Instagram basketball page if you wanted
to start branding himself
you can obviously start making content
on Instagram and putting on that
county's a huge account two million plus
where you got though right he's got 2.2
million followers on that account like
huge audience but I still think what's
amazing about Twitter is back to when
Paul George broke his leg during
something and he pees a penis
these players should not be playing in
the Olympics so whatever it is it's that
one piece of content in a Twitter
environment that this proportion can be
impactful too busy FaceTime and Bronwyn
pause I did more to you when they get
note
got to be off a million joules in if
they see you boys
tinkle teeth my fans Braille they'll
have aa computer screen I use contracts
with toilet paper I don't need no one's
favors and I don't [ __ ] with ladies I
manage my order my friends who help me
all for the love and never ask me
persist they say it's not a career that
don't pay the rent
though I love this I had to make it make
sense cuz I can fill up my list we work
day and night I see it in my safe I care
I think I'm upset I think she might be
right well [ __ ] trying my best
I waited all my life I've got a little
team some checks the right so seven out
used to be open mic ignore I know I
gotta hide I just keep planting and flat
and watching do roaming ghosts sitting
on oh you're home I'm booked it all
yourselves you turn around and you see
me grinning our bread and make sell
decisions I mentioned close to tours I'm
on y'all practice friend and I want and
they paid me in cash
bet they pay your waste and exposure I
made it you well here cuttin corners boy
y'all harm mine I mean how much you pay
for that cosign who you related to who's
writing all your rhymes it's like you
bought that comfortable loser they
wanted you to take an ailment I was
happy to do it I made it
you ain't expected I'm next you gotta
accept that if you slept on me to snow
you'll regret it
the prologue throwing away the split so
long add the cook up a tape debut so
strong could've just chill but add too
much to say it's for the family you
ain't president that's how I had to be
tsyganov were for now but you [ __ ]
ain't seen the last amigo
crushed his dead we're back to crushing
it
Tyler what's the subtitle crushing it
can remember what the exact subtitle is
how these are what how great
entrepreneurs build their businesses and
influence and how you can to crushing it
20:18 350 copies now it's not up yet I
did morning you when they di notice got
to be off I'm new get Jules in if they
see you boys take a peep my fans Braille
they'll have aa computer screen I use
contracts for the paper